hi I'm Erik Bosse and xmin Dark Phoenix
just revealed and cast interviews the
reason this movie was delayed so many
times it became a bit overshadowed by
Marvel Studios crowning moment with a
ventures endgame and Disney's
acquisition of all the Fox Marvel
properties like the x-men and Deadpool
and as we know from Ruffalo and Holland
putting superhero actors in front of the
press to try to explain the most
confusing aspects of these movies is
always a delight I'm gonna break down
what they said and what it needs for the
upcoming Dark Phoenix film and how these
x-men movies relate to the Marvel films
and this big family reunion that they're
about to have spoiler warning against
any my speculation into being around
another language okay recently yahoo UK
sat down with a cast of Dark Phoenix
including James McAvoy who plays Charles
Xavier Michael Fassbender Magneto sophie
Turner Jean Grey and Jessica Chastain
playing a new mystery villain character
McAvoy Fassbender said that this movie's
release was delayed from November 2018
to over a year and a half later because
the filmmakers rewrote in reshot the
entire third act because the movie that
they were making was too similar to
another superhero movie finale had to
change there was a lot of overlap in
parallels with another superhero movie
the chemo a while ago and we had no idea
that we were if there were spies on
certain we were basically incarcerated
yeah we went rolling through the same
source material
it seems you name each film so which
other super movie were they talking
about
most likely Captain Marvel Dark Phoenix
is an adaptation of Chris Claremont epic
Dark Phoenix saga in the 80s x-men
comics in which Jean Grey comes into
contact with the cosmic Phoenix force
and gets overtaken with a violent power
that she struggles to control meanwhile
Captain Marvel was adapted from a more
recent relaunch of the character in the
past decade with Air Force pilot Carol
Danvers taking on the title directly a
much more popular version of the Captain
Marvel comics than her previous
incarnation of Miss Marvel female
companion to the original male Captain
Marvel in the old comics the Captain
Marvel film that came out this year
began production in March 2017 and
wrapped in July 2017 Carol Danvers
struggles with memory loss brainwashed
the Cree into thinking the
shape-shifting scroll or evil with a
mentor figure restraining her inner
glowy powers until she lashes out
against everyone and blows up a bunch of
stuff in space just outside Earth's
orbit the Dark Phoenix movie began
shooting in June 2017 right as Captain
Marvel was rapping production and if
they were following many plot points
from the Dark Phoenix comics Jean Grey
would also turn against a mentor figure
trying to control her unleash an inner
glowy power and presumably also blow up
a bunch of stuff in space
Captain Marvel exists in the same Marvel
comic universe of the x-men do but these
movie universes have been separate
because until recently they were owned
by different film studios Marvel Studios
notoriously keeps their movie plot lines
tightly under wraps and the team working
on Dark Phoenix over at Fox in the
summer of 2017 would probably have no
way of knowing any similarities between
their film and a Captain Marvel film and
you just gotta sympathize with the Dark
Phoenix team because the Dark Phoenix
character in the comics is really the og
of this kind of character arc sure there
were other female badasses throughout
the years in Marvel comics before Dark
Phoenix saga but Claremont story was
really a huge game-changer
the first major instance of a comic
exploring the complex in a world of a
female superhero making her a figure to
be feared and respected it was awesome
when this happened and II could argue
without the Dark Phoenix saga being so
popular we never would have had a Carol
Danvers relaunch of Captain Marvel
decades later so really in the timing
has just been unfortunate Fox already
had it shot at adapting the Dark Phoenix
saga and x-men The Last Stand but
director Brett Ratner scaled it down to
a weird romantic subplot in a movie that
a lot of fans were back crazy about and
after The Last Stand the x-men franchise
gravitated more around the Wolverine
character and to a lesser degree
mystique adapting storylines like Days
of Future past Age of Apocalypse old man
Logan and just waited too long to take
another shot of Dark Phoenix look I
obviously have a lot of opinions about
these characters and it's because I've
always devoured comics and consumed
everything I can find about them
including any audio books on these
subjects which I discovered on audible
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
episode
audible has an insane selection of audio
books including one that I really liked
Marvel Comics the untold story by Sean
Haugh
takes you through the fascinating
history of Stanley Jack Kirby and the
others as their characters like the
x-men reflected social change throughout
the 20th century and how figures like
Jean Grey were so influential that rival
film studios and inverted ly
incorporated their story arcs you can
listen to audible while commuting
cooking cleaning in the waiting room at
the gym where for whatever reason I
never get too sweaty to tap that audible
app button and listen my favorite
audiobooks you can start listening with
a thirty-day audible trial and your
first audiobook plus two audible
originals are free just go to
audible.com slash new rock stars again
audible.com slash new rockstars AUD ible
comm slash any WRO c KS t ARS or txt new
rock stars - 500 500 okay let's get back
to the ways Dark Phoenix could still be
a great film if you continue to watch
that Yahoo interviews sophie turner goes
on to say that the third act changes
were for the best because now the story
ends with a grounded human conflict
instead of a CGI spectacle which to me
always sounds like one character holding
another character as they die but it is
still a superhero movie couldn't we
still have some pretty effects filling
the screen while that happens and as
recently Deadman stark once said why not
both really the most interesting change
to me involves Jessica Chastain's
character it's actually pretty hilarious
to hear Chastain try to describe her
trying to catch up with her character as
the rewrites and reshoots transformed it
my character changed a lot which is an
interesting thing because I'm not
playing someone from the comics so it
was always like everyday kind of trying
to figure out Who am I you know the
mystery of who is this character and
then understanding that also with the
reshoots you kind of go oh it's changing
it getting you know I mean it was like a
constant evolution
yikes folks no actor even one as
talented as Jessica Chastain is should
ever start every day of shooting
wondering who the hell is my character
but we the Nerds can wonder Chastain has
implied that her character was never
going to be someone specific from the
comics so that rules out the Shiar
empress lilandra her sister death bird
has has been speculated for and now it
sounds like she's going to be a new
original alien character who's trying to
help the alien d'bari
Empire but back at one point Jessica
Chastain's character was credited as
Smith and described
as a shapeshifter that could imply that
Chastain's character was originally
going to be a scroll the shape-shifting
race that appeared in Captain Marvel now
it was always a little unclear which
studio had the rights to the scroll
since in the comics they've always been
more associated with the Fantastic Four
which was a box property but no one
outside of Marvel Studios knew the
Captain Marvel film would be to the
scroll until concept art was leaked in
July 2017 when Dark Phoenix was already
a month into shooting at that point it's
likely that many of Chastain scenes
would have been shot as well as the
movie's original finale unless this is a
legal thing and Marvel had bought back
the rights to the scroll and the Dark
Phoenix team just somehow didn't know
that I really don't see a problem with
Dark Phoenix keeping its story the same
so what if Dark Phoenix ended up being a
little similar to Captain Marvel in 2016
Captain America Civil War had a lot of
similar elements to Batman V Superman
which came out a month before that movie
did and then what I didn't really care
it's Hollywood all of these stories are
derivative echoes of each other like I
can watch stranger things super 8 in the
it reboots even though they're all
essentially the same story in some cases
with the same actors and still enjoy all
of them pretty much the same so even if
Jean Grey's story arc ends up being
similar to Carol Danvers Dark Phoenix
could still be a better film than
Captain Marvel was so again to quote mr.
stark why not both comment down below
and tell me whether you think Dark
Phoenix was right to change its ending
or if it should have left it the same
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss subscribe to me rockstars thanks
for joining me and I'm gonna close out
with an impression of Red Skull in an
acapella singing group
oh wait yesterday's video already ended
that way damn oh I gotta do a new ending
you know what I get you now Dark Phoenix
[Music]